こんにちははじめシャツ大ですというわけで
これやばいんだったがうまい棒灸園弁がやるのかな
結構食ったんする前で枚なかったんで本当にものすごい数のうまい棒になってしまい
ましただけで今日はこのうまい棒皆さんに無料で配ら桜と思います
マジで多いですこれ全部ですからね
ニャル子これがにせるガッツ取れない僕があるんですよ
re
ん
あの100万円企画で軽い機陥ってわけじゃなかったんですけどそれなりの数を覚悟し
てうまい棒を買ったんですけど多すぎて実は会場借りたり色々してるとものすごいお金
がかかってしまってて参ったって感じです
まあでもそれで俺以外のみんなが営業になってくれるんだったら
会場一部運営費なんで
安いもんせてあげる地の皆さんうまい棒これ全部配っていこうと思います
いくら4 a
par
me
car
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
持ってん
持っています
あっはぁん
皆様今日
ware
お姉ちゃんああああ
rar
deji ありがとうございます
yeah
ん
ああああああ
n ame
[音楽]
はいというわけで甘いも90万円分ぐらいかな
を配り終わりました来てくださった皆様本当にありがとうございます
さあ
[音楽]
結構よ
はい
というわけでうまい棒配布会来てくださった皆様本当にありがとうございますが無事皆
様のおかげで全部名前も何かありました
[音楽]
フィア難しかったですねうまい棒なぁ本残ってるかわかんないしイベントに来る人が
全員100%車下もないから何人に何本あげればちゃんとなくなるのかっていうのが
わからなかったんでも配る数が本当に難しかったり接客北にもらえないというのもやだ
しあまりすぎると本来の目的を見失うことになってしまうし一応ですねあの来て
くださったと
全員に数は結構下がると思うんですけどうまい棒は全部変わることができました結構皆
さん喜んでくれて何よりでございます
[音楽]
カッター街に使うけんの目に9人に休憩なしでもうずっと配り続けてそういうことで腰
を痛めてしまいましたね私はそれでももうどう例えば100万円分前歯を買ってしまっ
た僕のせいなのでまぁそのおかげで何か皆さんとお話できたり間でできたんであの
結果をられてとこかなお暑い中来てくださった皆様ありがとうございました
ちょっとあの一言言いたいことがあるんですけども年各コメントとかリプとかで何か
甘いばそれ全部被災地に送ってくださいとか
中山洪水とかで大変な地域とかに家で前歯全部をくれよとか結構言われたりするんです
けども僕それは断じて違うかなと思っております
本当に今その地域にうまい棒が必要なのかと言われると僕はちょっとわからないでしょ
なんかむしろ必要ないものを必要ないものを必要ないときに送られる方がすごい
あの現地からすると迷惑な多いなのかなとか思いました
もちろん必要であれば僕は送りたいと思っておりますただその必要が必要じゃないかと
いう判断月
かないうちにもう一応ですね前も全部被災地に送ったりするのはちょっと俺は違うかな
と思いました
僕は何かあった時になんでもかんでも送っていいとは思っておりませんだからそういう
イベントするんだったら一サイズに遅れっていうコメントをたくさん見て
俺ずっとそれ今は今はね今は違うんじゃないかなって素直に思いました
なぜ僕は送りません今は必要か必要じゃないかと見極めて必要な時に担当
僕のできることをちゃんとやっていけると思いますだけで無事家にたっくさんたうまい
棒がなくなりましたが
うまい棒配るイベント結構いろいろお金
なかったんですようまい棒配るためにかかっとキング全部合計してみると第1隊
100万円でしたてっ
[音楽]
me
ni
バッハ